s'il ya un truc que j'ai test par dessus
tout c'est fait un ménage ne sais pas
vous mais pour moi c'est une perte de
temps sèche c'est du temps que je vais
occuper sonne si tout est bien dit comme
ça c'est du temps que j'ai passé au
final à nettoyer la maison et à ne pas
pouvoir travailler elle pas être
productif et je déteste vraiment
familial donc depuis quelques temps
j'utilise un robot ménager à la maison
de la marque robot rock
j'en ai déjà testé 2 buts est
aujourd'hui le 3ème et quand robot rock
et vient boire mais en interne d'un
nouveau produit c'est le robot rock le
s5 max est ce que tu veux le tester j'ai
dit oui parce que c'est un vrai gain de
temps parce que c'est une vraie belle
solution pour votre intérieur vous
prenez pas la tête alors c'est peut-être
pas le ménage fait dans tous les recoins
100% mais vous lestoille en tout cas
facilement 80 % de votre maison avec un
robot aspirateur comme ça ça c'est
nouveau c'est le s5 max que je trouve
vraiment y sera intéressant à des
marques comme c'est tout mignon c'est
vraiment cool c'est un beau produit
je vous en parle aujourd'hui on parle de
technologie je vous parle de produits
connectés pour la maison je vous parle
d' aspirateur intelligent qui vient
complètement optimisé le nettoyage de
votre maison et croyez moi ça c'est
vraiment à part
[Musique]
alors vous pouvez le dire comme ça des
euro bonds il n'a pas me faire mes
ongles
eh bien non détrompez-vous parce qu'en
fait garder mon sens un petit peu comme
ça vous avez une balayette la wii qui
tourne qui va sur le côté c'est votre
aspirateur il avance de bié tac hier par
paris repas et vous rabat toutes les
cochonneries surcoté et ils vous les
aspire directement en dessous nous avons
un aspirateur qui est quand même
vachement pratique très grand avec toute
cette zone l'action d'inspiration vous
avez un grand bac hà hùng que vous
mettez vous clip c'est là là vous avez
tout votre parti avec votre poussière
d'ailleurs je les nettoie y est j'ai
encore un peu de cochonneries la petite
balayette essayé pour revenir incliné le
tout ça marche
un aspirateur robot avec un petit laser
qui avance ce qui fait ce qui va
cartographier grâce au laser il verra
les obstacles et mûri la cartographie
votre maison il va venir
évitez les obstacles et surtout il va se
souvenir de la configuration votre
maison de vos pièces s'il fait à un prix
de l'once nouvelle application vous
allez pouvoir lui dire maintien pendant
telle pièce nettoyer telle zone devrait
pouvoir rider tout ça enfin je vous
explique c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intelligent un robot mal en moi en
tout cas je suis vraiment content
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai qu'à l'abattoir de
robots aspirateurs on se dit d'un côté
c'est vrai j'ai un robot qui est là qui
aspire pratiquement fait il fait pas que
ça c'est un robot deux ans non il va
aspirer
il ya aussi une serpillière vous pouvez
choisir de mettre une paire mettre en
fonction de ce que vous voulez faire
s'ils voulaient par nos soins une zone
avec un tapis et bien ce mois là vous
mettez pas la serpillière si vous êtes
dans une zone où il n'y a pas de tapis
il voulait nettoyer le sol
eh bien vous remplissez le bac à eau
vous mettez la serpillière et ça va vous
nettoyez votre intérieur
on apprend les avoir d'eau de 290000 est
libre vous pouvez laver pendant deux
heures de suite sans problème 186 mètres
carrés on vient vous est quand même
relativement tranquille à moins que vous
ayez un château voilée dans
l'appartement sinon vous êtes quand même
vraiment peinard comment ça marche c'est
très simple vous avez votre smartphone
avec une application à l'intérieur
l'application robot rock elle est
planqué justifie en dessous votre
application dans laquelle vous allez
connecter votre aspirateur et vont
pouvoir communiquer ensemble et vous
allez tout paramétrer à partir de là
nous allons pouvoir venir aspiré votre
maison nettoie votre maison extrêmement
facilement dans votre application vous
retrouvez votre beau pour vous avez
évidemment votre profil peut venir
régler votre profil mais de vos
paramètres comme vous souhaitez mais
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
rentrer dans notre beau dans votre
application vous avez le plan que votre
appartement ça ces derniers nettoyage
que j'ai fait ça nettoyage très très
très très ciblée j'ai donc les
différentes couleurs de mes pièces sont
connus grande pièce de vie entre et
bureaux bon j'avais pas mal de bazar
donc il n'a pas pu circuler partout il y
avait permis un échange peut donc
choisir les endroits où je veux qu'il
aille je peux sélectionner une pièce tu
vas là tu vas là tu vas là ça c'est
vraiment très très très pratique lorsque
j'ai vraiment faire du nettoyage ciblé
peut lui dire tu vas partout dans toutes
les pièces ou alors carrément
sélectionner une zone par exemple up
ici tu vas uniquement dans la cuisine tu
ne vas pas ailleurs thierry toyer la
cuisine j'appuie sur clean ont deux
parties
[Musique]
oui
j'ai aussi la possibilité d'éditer mes
pièces je peux rassembler plusieurs
pièces en une
je peux les diviser par exemple ici me
mettre la partie cuisine mais que la
partie salon je peux aussi complètement
dire customiser c'est vraiment très
pratique je te définir des zones où je
ne veux pas qu'ils aillent nogo zone par
exemple mettre un mur invisible aux
normes écoute tu va aspirer par tous
sauf cette zone là je ne veux pas que
dans cette zone là tu n'iras pas tout
simplement parce que il va y avoir
quelque chose que je veux protéger je
pas par exemple qu'il ait tourné autour
des jeunes filles je veux pas qu'ils
aillent autour de la litière du chat
[Musique]
je peux définir donc un mur invisible
une négo zone explosive bien
complètement réglé mon niveau de
nettoyage par exemple dire écoute tu vas
y aller tranquille où tu vas le pirée
doucement ou alors tu vas y aller un peu
plus fort mais un mode silencieux non
mode normal plutôt équilibré tu veux y
aller comme ça tu vas mettre le turbo
basse et quand même pas mal de
cochonneries ou alors maximum des
puissances l'histoire vous faire le gros
nettoyage et toutes inspirées
pareil pour los payos du tout un tout
petit peu d'eau carrément beaucoup d'eau
et alors là qui va à fond tu nettoies
tout faut que ça brille vous n'êtes pas
mal de paramètres c'est vrai notamment
un mode tapis ça s'est vraiment bien
lorsque vous avez un talent puis
lorsqu'il va détecter un tapis il assume
être aspiré beaucoup plus fort il va
adapter l'inspiration par rapport au
tapis vous pouvez aussi choisir un mode
pour ne pas déranger par exemple entre
22h et 8h du matin tu ne vas pas aspirer
comme ça au moins vous êtes tranquille
mais n'a même plus loin vous avez un
mode timer ou là vous allez bien pouvoir
le programme et moi par exemple je les
programmer pour qu'il parte à 9 heures
du matin tous les jours de la semaine je
règle mon niveau d'aspiration à riom se
produire maintient le mercredi du coeur
bureau max le reste de la semaine qui va
quand même de façon un peu plus
tranquille tu veux sectionner des pièces
dans lesquelles je veux qu'il aille une
fois que j'ai enregistrée et bien voyez
je peut l'activer ou le désactiver
comme faire réellement ce que je veux le
programme et par le lourd programme et
par zone c'est vraiment vraiment cool je
peux aussi lui dire vivre ici avec le
petit pick and go
je sélectionne la j'appuie gauzère et il
est parti
[Musique]
j'ai toute la mémoire de mes anciens
nettoyage et ça m'impressionne ça c'est
vraiment extrêmement linéaire d'une
pièce à l'autre voyez tous les endroits
où il est passé
c'est clean de chéquiers et lorsqu'il
est en train de nettoyer lorsqu'il est
en train d'aspirer vous voyez le trait
se dessiner moment où ils avancent c'est
vraiment vraiment fluide
le nettoyage est extrêmement fluide
grâce aux capteurs qui va la vendre dès
qu'il va toucher up his décale il avance
pisé qu'à lille avant 6 égal avec le
laser qui va venir cartographier
facilement votre maison l'inspiration
est vraiment très très simple
technologiquement saut final très malin
ça nettoie très facilement et c'est
vraiment très très très pratique moment
où il est en train d'avancer moment où
il entre un des tauliers vous pouvez
vraiment le suivre sur la carte vous le
voyez se déplacer c'est vraiment très
pratique parce qu'imaginez vous êtes
dans votre bureau dans une autre pièce
vous êtes isolé pour travailler pour
faire ce que vous voulez eh bien vous
voyez exactement gouverner ça vous
permet aussi de voir dans combien de
temps durera phil mikelson est nettoyé
vous pouvez donc y aller et des
galipettes dans laquelle vous êtes lui
va se rendre il passe partout ils
montent jusqu'à 2 cm de hauteur dont
vous êtes quand même relativement
tranquille si vous avez des pas de porc
des tapis et en plus si vous avez un
escalier si vous avez une marche si vous
avez peur qu'ils jettent dans le vide
bye bye je saute et bien non j'étais
tranquille une fois de plus il ya des
capteurs il va pouvoir détecter le vide
il va avancer s'arrêter continue à
avancer à se déplacer donc vous n'avez
absolument aucune crainte à avoir de ce
côté là vous pouvez donc l'utiliser pour
respirer toute votre maison facilement
où est donc mettre des barrières si vous
voulez pas que les gens du job vous
pouvez lui dire va doper les hommes
femmes et hoyé telles pièces telles péri
mais de telles pièces en fer telle pièce
en entier pourrait venir tout customiser
vos pièces votre intérieur
le paramétrique comme vous voulez le
lancer quand vous voulez on est donc sur
un assistant de nettoyage vraiment très
intelligente absolument paramétrable et
ça c'est vraiment génial et moi je les
utilise déjà depuis allégées dire fait
une bonne année et depuis je me passe
pas je vous dis ça en toute honnêteté
parce que si je n'y croyais pas si
j'aimais pas ce produit je n'en
parlerais pas je les aime beaucoup il
marche très bien
si vous n'avez jamais goûté aux
aspirateurs robots c'est pour moi une
solution qui vient vraiment vous changer
la vie
et même si vous le configurer
extrêmement bien ce sera complètement
transparent vous partez au travail à
telle heure une demi heure après il y va
il fait le nettoyage il rentrer à sa
base
vous avez juste à vider le bac à remplir
l'eau mais c'est vraiment facile et
c'est même complètement transparent vous
avez plus qu à regarder ensuite
directement sur votre implication vous
monitorer le travail qui a été fait
c'est vraiment hypra simple je serai
beaucoup alors s'approcher coûte aux
environs des 550 euros je sais pas si
vous
lisez-vous un aspirateur robot je sais
pas si une solution comme celle là comme
le s5 max de rembrandt peut vous
intéresser
moi tout ça vraiment intéressant si vous
utilisez nos robots aspirateurs dites
moi si vous êtes satisfaits ou
satisfaits tant bas en commentaire
personnellement je le suis je le
recommande
parce que croyez moi depuis que je
laisse ça me solutionne la vie je
m'embête plus à passer le balai la
serpillière je fais de temps en temps
pour les quelques zones où il ne peut
pas aller mais le reste du temps c'est
lui qui fait absolument tout le job vous
invite donc à dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire est ce que son
robot pourrait vous intéresser si vous
avez des questions ou interrogations
pourraient y aller pour cela vous
embrasse demandez vous dès demain
ciao